we're young hip and innovative but
financially our generation is pretty
screwed we came of age in the worst
economic crisis since the Great
Depression and you better believe we
felt it all our lives they told us you
go to college you get a degree you'll
get a good job but they were wrong we
make up most of the minimum wage
workforce one in six of us still lived
with our parents and our student debt
has reached crushing levels and for a
lot of it's bad news we can blame our
parents generation the baby boomers who
came of age in a time of prosperity are
passing on to their children a broken
country with an enormous federal deficit
and little hope of job prospects our
health care system is barely functional
infrastructure arguably pathetic and
income inequality is the highest it's
been since 1928 and yet somehow we're
still stubbornly optimistic about our
financial future more than 80 percent of
us say we currently have enough money to
lead the lives that we want or at least
expect to in the future how the hell can
we be so positive when things of looks
so bleak
well for one thing folks our age sure
know how to adapt when it comes to
making money we know how to get creative
38% of us work as freelancers in the gig
economy piecing together multiple jobs
at the same time these jobs like driving
a lift or running errands with
TaskRabbit in turn contribute to the
share economy which use a technology to
make our lives more efficient now of
course we share autonomy shortcuts
mostly benefit those who can afford to
pay you to build that IKEA desk
many of us value the nature of our work
and its impact over our paychecks a
recent study found that 72% of
millennial workers so that they were
ready to sacrifice a higher salary if it
meant more fulfilling work we're good at
budgeting we gotta be when half of us
are using more than half of our monthly
income to pay off various kinds of debt
which is part of the reason why we're
careful spenders we rent instead of buy
we choose to leave suburbia for cities
where public transport and ride-sharing
is more available more affordable and
more on
men shall be friendly then owning a car
all smart decisions when you can't
afford a mortgage because you're paying
off all that student debt but spending
less will cost the economy and better
spenders doesn't mean better savers 37%
of us have less than $5,000 safe and 22%
of us don't have any savings at all
retirement savings but fat we're
revitalizing cities that were ruined on
our parents watch many US cities like
Detroit Cleveland and Baltimore have
been hollowed out by the collapse of US
manufacturing followed by the 2008
financial crisis but a wave of 20 and
30-somethings are reshaping the urban
landscape in these cities to some this
is straight-up gentrification but to
others it's urban renewal many cities
know that in order to become the
economic powerhouses of the future they
need to do highly-educated and mobile
young people some cities have LED
advertising campaigns offering
internships housing subsidies even
student loan reimbursements to encourage
us to move in and revitalize their
economies so yeah we've been dealt a
pretty crappy hand of cards but you
gotta admit we know how to hustle so how
often you figure you about the economy
these days and what kind of economy what
we passed down to our kids
young and broke you're not alone they
told us you work hard you get an
education and you'll get a good job but
they were wrong